all right the Border battle in Texas at
the Rio Grand intensifying over razor
wire as governor abot of Texas asserts
his State's right to defend itself
against then essentially an invasion and
as you can see on the big wall right
there 25 Republican Governors are
backing him including as you zoom in on
Oklahoma there he is Kevin stit the
Governor of Oklahoma he's up on the big
wall and he's live right now from
Oklahoma governor good morning to you
hey good morning thanks for having me on
you bet okay so uh why have you and 23
or 24 other Governors all Republicans
said uh we're going to help uh Mr Abbott
out in
Texas well I mean it's pretty simple for
us for Oklahoma I think for most
Americans uh this is just common sense
in Texas there's 28 ports of entry and
it's a federal law that it's illegal to
enter anywhere but those points of Entry
I mean the last time I flew to Mexico I
had to land at an airport and show them
my passport and so the fact that the
federal government Biden is cutting
Razer wire it just it just makes no
sense at all and so yes we have the
right to defend our country against
Invasion and what else would you call it
if you've got 6 million people coming
through illegally no exactly and I know
uh the former president Donald Trump has
suggested to all the Republican
Governors out there uh send members of
your State's national guard in your case
Governor would be the Oklahoma National
Guard send him down to Texas to help
Greg Abbott are you going to do
that absolutely you know I've done it
once before and we're looking I already
talked to my tag my general manino we've
already started putting the numbers
together uh we'll be in contact with
Governor Abbott uh but you know we also
need some common sense here what is the
Biden Administration doing why would
they talk about federalizing the Texas
guard why are they directing border
patrol the American people need to ask
themselves why are they directing the
border patrol to cut Razer wire this
sakes no sense this is beyond politics
uh I I just don't understand what's
happening right you know what you just
touched on an important point I'm going
to bring that up there are a number of
Democrats who are calling on President
Biden you know what you need to do you
need as you just mentioned you need to
federalize the Texas National Guard what
that means is then no longer is Greg
Abbott their boss they are working for
the
commander-in-chief uh Mr Biden here's
have you thought this through if you
send your Oklahoma National Guard down
there and a bunch of other states send
them down there you know all Joe Biden
has to do is federalize all of them next
thing you know they are doing uh
essentially support work for the uh
border patrol who are down there right
now just trying to process the the
invasion of migrants your your National
Guard could be working for Joe
Biden yeah well here's the deal I've
been on the border I've talked to the
Border agents even the Border agents
themselves are scratching their head but
but these are good Americans and they're
trying to obey their boss and but they
don't agree with that policy either and
of course the National Guard soldiers
they're Texans and they're Oklahomans
and they're Tennessee folks and and and
these are just Americans and they don't
like what's going on so you would really
be putting our soldiers in a tough tough
situation to protect their their states
against fentanyl deaths and against uh
illegal immigrants and and terrorists in
a lot of cases just to just to appease
some some Administration that has a
political agenda that's the only
possible explanation is they're wanting
to nationalize and get a bunch of Voters
in that they think is going to swing
elections that's the only logical
explanation and it and it's absolutely
illogical to think that we have leaders
that are more focused on the next
election instead of doing what's right
for America well it's really something
uh let's see what happens next Governor
sit thank you very much for joining us
today from Oklahoma I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis